the european commission presented its
long-awaited strategy for sustainable
and smart mobility according to it more
than 80 initiatives are to be launched
in the current legislative term
as socialists and democrats we are more
than welcoming this strategy
notably the revision of the co2
standards for cars
vans and trucks and the three million
public charging points
and thousand hydrogen filling stations
that should be in place by 2030
as well as the inclusion of shipping and
aviation
in the european trading system i am
happy to finally see
the long-awaited strategy for
sustainable and smart transport
we need to make all modes of transport
sustainable as soon as possible
and therefore i'm especially glad to see
that the strategy
includes proposal for sustainable fuels
in both
aviation and maritime with regards to
consumer rights
i'm also extremely happy to see that the
proposal
from us socialists and democrats on
creating a european travel guarantee
fund
is part of the strategy we cannot
continue to force
consumers to bail out airlines and
travel agents
however as socialist we would have liked
to see
stronger proposals on workers rights we
need to make sure
that the new strategy for the future of
transport also entails good working
condition
for all those working in transport and
we will continue
to push for concrete proposals from the
commission to improve working conditions
in transport finally i can promise that
we will make
our outmos to ensure that all proposals
and targets are ambitious
and implemented in due time to create a
sustainable
transport in the future